- I was a teacher for 10 years
in Kalamazoo Public Schools.
They're a mid-size urban
district in southwest Michigan,
and my first three years
I taught algebra I,
geometry, algebra II,
the core math classes,
but I also taught an
introductory statistics course.
And then in my fourth year teaching,
I started teaching AP Statistics
and taught it for my last
seven years teaching.
I love how AP courses
really stretch students
and give them a chance to
really challenge themselves
and take on a subject
and a curriculum that
is just a little bit harder than
a standard high school
curriculum might be for them.
And it prepares them for a
level of rigor in college
that can be intimidating
for a lot of students
when they first enter a college course,
but students who take AP classes,
in my experience, tend
to feel more comfortable
once they get to college.
I discovered Khan Academy when
a coworker of mine showed it to me,
and this was back when
Khan Academy first started,
and a coworker showed it
to me and I could actually
get students the practice they needed,
often they needed at home as well.
Because our students
would for various reasons
miss a lot of days of school,
and so getting students
the help they needed
in the class or outside of the classroom,
Khan Academy was a great help.
When I was an AP teacher,
I liked to use a variety of methods
for engaging my students with the concepts
we were learning,
so I would some days like to
give a lecture on the material
or other days maybe play
a game or do a simulation
or maybe other days let them be self-paced
in some review problems.
And Khan Academy offers a
way for teachers to do that
in their classrooms.
You have content creators like myself
working at Khan Academy
who have been teachers,
teaching AP for many years,
and we also have external
reviewers who work closely
with The College Board
and who are table readers
and grade the AP Test,
all working together to
make sure that the content
is high quality for students.
My entire career as a
teacher I felt like I was
doing the world good by teaching
multiple groups of students a subject
that I thought would be incredibly useful
for their professional, academic,
and everyday lives because
teaching statistics,
I feel like I'm equipping students
with how to make informed
decisions in their lives.